j'ai envie qu'on toute la troupe de ma
vie je veux pisser dans mon pantalon
qu'est-ce que je t'avais dit rien qui
fout la trouille
ça fait pas là ses pairs alors de quoi
gérer un type qui nous a parlé d'une
société il te propose de la peur à la
demande pour vendre quelque chose
si vraiment vous voulez savoir ce que
c'est la peur appeler ce numéro doit de
ne pas faire appel à eux j'ai entendu
dire que ces gens là avaient poursuivi
ma patronne dans un parking en plein
milieu de la nuit
la société et pouvant on peut signer un
contrat
[Musique]
sur les lieux d'un trafic coindre
biocides
c'est pas notre maison c'est aux
posteurs suspect principal
c'est quoi c'est tout vente
quoi disjoncter
t'as pas compris ce qu'on a dit cette
société dangereusement gentils petits
cochons sur dix petits cochons est ce
que je peux entrer
pour elle de moments totu retrouve bien
alors tu ferais sans voler ta maison
c'est quoi cette société on m'avait fait
croire qu'ils avaient tué pour ses menus
à leurs fans de cinéma tu aurais dû le
savoir c'est si un jeu tout simplement
the shining scream tous
[Musique]
tu trouves pas
ludique qui se passe quelque chose de
très étrange duo carte médiocre ouvert